we live in interesting times there's
lots going on at the moment and this is
just
a snapshot of some of the things that
are actually in the news i'm actually
not going to necessarily go to all these
links
but i just wanted to raise your
awareness as if it's not already raised
about some of the things that are
currently going on
now in the session after lunch
we are actually going to pick up on some
of these issues
and present you with some data and some
research into
what people are actually finding out and
what we can maybe do about it so i'm not
actually going to talk about it now but
rather just use this as a signpost for
things to think about
in your
sessions after we have the teach meet
presentations we're going to break up
into groups and dive to rooms for
discussion
and maybe these are some of the things
that you'd like to actually talk about
so we do know that there are declining
enrolments
in the mathematics two unit course for
the hsc
and more and more students are choosing
to study general mathematics
that is a worry
we do have some data to share with you
later on today about what we think is
going on but i'm sure the teachers in
the room will also have stories to share
about this issue it is a problem
associated with that we know there's a
shortage of qualified mathematics
teachers
i'm sure again some of you here are in
schools where you have teachers teaching
out of field teachers teaching in year 7
and 8 who are not qualified math
teachers
there is a shortage whilst we've got a
lot of new teachers in this room
it does appear that particularly in some
schools in some areas it is difficult to
find teachers
interestingly this one this little
article was in the daily telegraph in
january should mathematics actually be
compulsory for the hsc that might be
something that you actually would like
to talk about in your discussion groups
i personally don't agree with that
and there's some
reasons why i don't agree with it i
don't think that forcing students to do
mathematics with the hsc would it
actually improve standards at all which
was one of the arguments and i think
adrian piccoli endorsed that argument uh
i would prefer that everyone chooses
mathematics because they
okay we've also got some uh recently in
the age adam spencer wrote an article
about the atar
and whether the atar is a game to secure
the highest scores which that's a quote
from some independent school principals
um he actually uh it's a very
interesting article actually it's well
worth the read i will make sure that
this powerpoint by the way is available
to everybody so we're actually going to
make sure that as much of this
information as possible can be shared
more of that later
we've also earlier in the year we had a
forum here on first year mathematics and
whether the students coming to
university to do science and engineering
related courses were actually well
prepared in mathematics we all know that
in the university handbook it says that
the presumed knowledge is extension one
but we have a fair bit of evidence that
in schools
careers advisors and possibly even maths
teachers are saying you don't have to
worry about that you can do a two-week
bridging course and you'll be fine
well we know that in fact that's not
sufficient so there are some issues
around the fact that we don't have
prerequisites
very recently akara released a report on
the effectiveness of naplan and guess
what the first recommendation was
that the score should be released to
schools much sooner
i think we've all been saying that for
years wouldn't that be wonderful
okay we know we've got a review of
national curriculum it will be very
interesting to see what the findings
from that are
the pisa results for 2012 came out the
end of last year and of course we had
the usual
we are falling behind in australia what
are we going to do about it and finally
most recently we have a review of
teacher education by the way this is i
think the 40th teacher education review
since 1970. the 40th
review of teacher education
so a lot of money is being spent on
reviews
um personally um i'm not convinced that
it's as bad as the ministers suggest it
might be but then perhaps i've got a
vested interest i might be very biased
so there's lots going on
we live as i've said here we live in a
dynamic space
no one is ever satisfied it seems with
what we do
and yet we know
the research provides sound advice about
the way forward in mathematics education
we are often the whipping boy
unfortunately for
some of these things that we read in the
press which which i find very
disheartening